depuis le début du déconfinement le 11
mai les forêts yvelinois sont de nouveau
accessibles aux promeneurs et elles ont
été prises d'assaut depuis pour des
balades dans cet habitat naturel des
animaux sauvages qui s'étaient habitués
peut-être à une certaine quiétude
bonsoir michel béal
mais vous êtes le directeur de l'agencé
territoriale ile de france ouest de
lodève le nfc bien sûr la l'office
national des forêts déjà est ce que
cette réouverture des forêts une bonne
nouvelle que les yvelinois les
franciliens se réapproprie à nouveau cet
espace
c'est bien sûr une bonne nouvelle pour
les habitants et qui ont été confinés
qui sont restés de longues longues
semaines à la maison et aujourd'hui on
voit bien de par la fréquentation des
forêts depuis depuis quelques semaines
qu'ils avaient besoin de ça qu'ils
viennent nombreux très très très
nombreux même de mémoire de forestiers
en ap et pas vu autant de monde en forêt
en forêt dans les yvelines en forêt de
saint germain pour écrabouiller ou dans
les forêts très proche de paris ça
s'explique aussi parce que il ya encore
la semaine dernière ou l'avant
seuls les forêts étaient ouvertes les
parcs et jardins étaient encore fermés
et donc les parties jardin ouvert que
depuis le week-end de deux parcs offrent
donc les forêts où beaucoup de visites
et justement avec cette grande présence
humaine en forêt comment les animaux
sauvages ont-ils vécu ce ce
déconfinement eux qui s'étaient habitués
peut-être une certaine tranquillité
absolument il s'était notamment les
animaux on connaît qu'on voit le plus
souvent comme les oiseaux comme les
mammifères et dans nos forêts il ya des
cerfs et chevreuils et sangliers et ont
également beaucoup évidemment d'oiseaux
d'oiseaux sauvages et bien ces
animaux-là avait pris l'habitude le dès
le 15 mars dès le 17 pages ne plus avoir
beaucoup de monde voire pas du tout et
donc qu'ils étaient moins farouche il
été moins heureux - furtif il donc pour
nous forestier qui auront pu continuer
d'exercer nos missions et nos métiers
même avec le
compliments on pouvait voir beaucoup
plus facilement des animaux en forêt de
versailles en forêt de meudon en forêt
de rambouillet parce que ils étaient au
moins à pleurer lui avalisé témoin par
le public
les promeneurs ou même par les usagers
de la route parce qu'il y avait aussi
moins de circulation dans l'hérault qui
traverse les forêts ça on les voyait
davantage à proximité des routes c'est
ça c'est ces animaux s'ils appuient
aussi et donc on a pu s'apercevoir par
exemple que des oiseaux pourtant des
voix rare avait puni chez en bordure de
chemin
on a vu des pics des pics épeiches des
piques par avoir investi des arbres des
qualités tillich dans des cavités dans
les arbres bon creux et qu'il était des
fois tout près d'un chemin forestier
alors qu'ils ne l'auraient pas fait
l'année d'avant parce que c'est un
chouette était très fréquentée par des
piétons
donc c'est les cinquante ans qu'on
puisse faire passer ce message
le public est vraiment très nombreux
donc faites attention c'est une période
de fragilité pour la nature
c'est l'époque des mises bas il ya des
jeunes des jeunes des jeunes chevreuil
par exemple et donc c'est obligatoire
d'avoir son chien en laisse jusqu'au 30
juin
c'est réglementaire pour que les animaux
même si c'est des chien d'appartement et
ils ont quand même un certain c'est
qu'il faut pas qu'ils dérangent les
animaux et pareil pour les niches et les
oiseaux qu'on peut voir on peut entendre
des fois d'ailleurs il faut pas s'en
approcher éviter de d'aller dans les
sous bois
on conseille que rester sur les chemins
et surtour et de continuer d'avoir le
geste citoyen de ramener ces déchets on
a énormément de déchets depuis quelques
jours le week-end dernier le week end de
pentecôte a apporté beaucoup de déchets
par les preneurs
on trouve des masques malheureusement
artères confort et c'est scandaleux et
donc ils ont demande vraiment à ce que
les habitants qui ont bénéficié
maintenant de cette forêt puisse aussi
être prêts goûteuse
gilles en ra mais tous leurs péchés leur
éthique détruit non voilà pour pour ses
conseils c'est dire que si on dresse un
premier bilan de ce déconfinement du
retour des événements en forêt il ya
quelques aspects négatifs vous le disiez
notamment la recrudescence des déchets
qui sont qui sont trouvés en forêt voilà
évidemment on savait on comprend le
besoin de nature c'est un besoin
physique de faire un peu de marche un
peu de sport mais c'est aussi un besoin
physique c'est à dire de pouvoir
ce petit chic de pouvoir s'aérer s'aérer
l'esprit aussi mais voilà secondes
devant tu sais que qu'il faut c'est une
nature c'est une telle diversité fragile
faisons en sorte aussi de la protégée de
la préserver et pour ne pas déranger les
animaux de ramener ces déchets on n'est
pas dans un parc urbain ne l'est pas en
ville il n'y a pas de corbeil
il faut avoir le geste citoyen de
reprendre un petit sac qui de ramener
ces déchets rabbit et une dernière
question concernant le aux élèves
comment c'était justement à adapter à
cette situation vous le disais tout à
l'heure vous avez pu davantage observées
dans meilleures conditions les animaux
est ce que vos activités vos missions
ont été impactés pendant pendant cette
période oui il ya eu un impact
évidemment comme comme tout le monde
parce qu'on n'y était pas préparée donc
les les premiers jours les premières
semaines n'ont pu être ont ils même que
les activités individuelles
le métier de forestier terrain c'est un
métier aussi seul où on travaille mais
seul en forêt donc ça s'était toujours
possible et on a pu continuer mais une
partie de nos activités
ce fait est atteint 3 à 4 à 5 personnes
ensemble et bien sûr là il s'est passé
un mois et ce n'est que vers le 15 avril
que les activités collectives les
activités coordonnées ont pu reprendre
et c'est vrai que les forestiers
notamment ceux qui travaillaient en
forêt et travailler seuls ont pu voir la
forêt d'arles et les deux mois
nous en voyons tout à fait nouveaux
inédits dîner d'hier on avait notamment
dans les yvelines jamais vu évidemment
les forêts comme ça parce que les forêts
sont toujours parcourue par de
nombreuses personnes
et si on regroupera plusieurs décennies
et par exemple au début du 20e siècle
c'était aussi des charbonniers qui
vivent près des bûches ou qui vivent
leur vie en fait de tout temps la forêt
a été très occupé merci michel vial
d'avoir est avec nous merci renversé
revoir et merci et je rappelle que vous
êtes le directeur de l'agencé
territoriale ile de france ouest de
l'eau nf l'office national des forêts